my friend if I set these things in my
country where I was born I had couple of
drinks yeah and I bet you're jumping all
over the place
you're we are one of my favorite walls
Pierre Suleiman submarines [ __ ]
Lally Lizzie halakha - salois one thing
I like about you at least you're polite
I don't ask I like to guide me from a
juvenile wear my clothes had holes in
the eye my eye fro is picky - the night
east
maschino and Musashi nice no Lacey's
inner Archie's new millennium my I'll
introduce myself
yes so what's your name what's your name
Ali Ali Ali my name is Alma army I'm all
right I was a very very religious family
I'm a doctor you know what whatever
religion Turkey and I'm always friends
anyway so yeah massacred one of you
rings are tell me a bit about it yeah
did it yeah no no just once they didn't
broke it many times
[Music]
the history which I know they first it
will try to probably yeah okay the point
is what then 835 men 12 year old boys 12
we are working because what prophet said
if somebody's got here yeah kill him
no no brother twelve-year-old boys a few
week here 11 euros the definitions are
arbitrary do you know in Pakistan they
kill they attack the school and they
killed 500 children and those 500
children when they believe on kill them
they they give the exact justification
of an aggressor
[Music]
because firstly if I'm going in killing
innocent people is wrong from the get-go
[Music]
what about I completely okay just give
me a second I am NOT going to justify
the Imperial killings I condemn them yes
and I condemn killings in Iraq Syria
every year but I condemn the killings by
Muslims Christians yes I do
and Jews and Jews yes I will be no no no
no I'm not talking about Muslim for me
I'm I would condemn anyone who would
kill humanity okay why do you say
because Muslims are a wolf in sheep's
clothing so I'm a Muslim my friend if I
said these things in my country when I
was born I had couple of drinks yeah
that's right but if I did all these
things in the contributor I was born I
would be killed because no I'm not upset
about it okay switch me and that will
happen anywhere any country so if you
could commit treason
you know you've ever put you in jail no
they won't admit no they wouldn't now I
commit a treason against my own country
Jesus is that why
a few months okay listen
Dino battle of Weber yes so Sophia's
husband was killed in the morning yes
her husband her father was killed in the
evening yes and then she became the wife
of the Prophet even though even though
her own choice the Prophet said to
Arkham City
I know it's my funny listen my friend
yes then I'm ready do you know a sahabi
was standing outside with a sword yes
yes so the Prophet said if you want I
can you know you claim that my favorite
was all of us yeah and this is a
reminder to us that it doesn't matter
how much you memorize the guidance in
and we also responds hello guys me and
yourself let's get caught up in our fate
they claim they know yeah I can tell you
quite a lot but it's not a fact I take
your word that I believe you know since
you have proven it yeah
so one team is now if we won I can look
at the [ __ ] light from an angle and
say you know what this looks a bit you
know I could assume the worst and
everything he does he's marriage to sign
them his marriage to I shot Sofia
yet Letta managed to cookies as well
that was my that's what you cream so
anybody that's looking with something to
pick will find someone if this was your
own father and you knew your father and
unique father was a good man
I think interesting things you say you
know I know and these are things that we
church you thing that oh he must have
done this without reason
how can you be married I should because
he had some kind of lust for a child you
don't know that so the point is that
when we do catch it the difference
between me and you is what you believe
the preliminary I should I believe my I
should I believe we took the light
please I just know like guys don't put
the my own voice down so the thing is
look the difference between viewers its
Muslimin a me as a River chase now I
know the same information is you I'm
just in a muslim' strong in favor you
are not what is the different you know I
should marriage you know a teacher's
marriage you know the purpose was you
know one of the house if I eat this
believer I believe we'll the point is
this when I look at the matter
I know catch it without I keep system
six seven years ago
yeah so I put you so what oh yeah Olivia
I know enemies they are like in Syrians
no this church so what I've seen is I
had to go and research his life in an
unbiased because if I start looking at
you all your profit evasion into oh my
gosh
look my friend five cups you're polite I
did hockey when Elena it was 13 years
with yes and how many people became
Muslim in Mecca I'll tell you hundreds
so in I am in the prophet's life in
Mecca I am very sure it was more than a
hundred my speech in his message there
was nearly as much of that yet no no
indeed it was them who are checking me
first dragon army can I just ask you one
question for me okay I'll ask you one
question there is a surah in quran which
is called surah fulfilled yeah alam tara
kayfa
Allah who can be a stabbing field I am
yet I'll pay no heed Lina marsala I am
siren of a thief Tommy him with a jar of
immensity pahala who can't swim banku
yes so in that surah there's a talk
about too much light you can get close
so in that suitor there's too much
talking about elephants now we know in
the Arabs arid land elephants couldn't
exist they won a lephant needs 1000
liter of water okay per day which was
not there in Mecca or Sanaa Yemen from
Yemen
i-i've been to Yemen up into humus
machine and I've been to all those areas
okay and there is not a single single
yeah they came to sorry it's a divine
word okay I will feed how does that show
the Quran is not from God when you have
no evidence to prove that this can
happen you're claiming that enemy needs
1,000 reasons with water they came from
another land yeah and they know Quran
said that the Arabs were right it was
Ali Ali Ali humans have been in this
world for forty thousand years
okay maybe more okay but the current
evidence is forty thousand ten thousand
years ago we started colonizing and we
started wicked being community Jesus
came two and a half thousand years and
then Islam nearly thousand
turn it later okay now my second point
is about caterers with well you see what
no well you have I'm making them I got
an eye condition we are I'll end up so
Cajun estimate it was like two years ago
it was a a big scientific physics thing
yeah going on King's College I brought
my son as well we were looking at the
Astra no me and there was a big black
rock you know I've done many humans in
hutch you know because my because of my
parents
so anyway and suddenly Beauty College
Wow so I set to the guy who was standing
on the salt
so can I touch it he's like why do you
want to touch it because it was in Goss
I said well I used to be a Muslim and he
took it out because you know when they
were fighting about building had been
there you know so it seems like so happy
it is this these stories to me don't
mean anything because you're just coming
to telling stories are you at mine you
know no chains killers Abu Oh Beza
above a abou available under our Sun and
Ashwin Skinner Muhammad bin Abu Bakr's
son you don't believe in coach
well it was good to speak to you one
thing I like about you at least you're
polite
I don't ask I like to guide me for me
the biggest religion is humanity I save
lives
howdy well save nice what do you mean by
same guys I'm a doctor that's good
that's good wait deceive songs
thank you